[Music]
thank you
hello we are back and you are welcome
back to for more scrutiny and revelation
of what's happening in the world of
climate things may get a little bumpy
later in the show so I'll need to be
safe as we dive into the divisive issue
of carbon offsetting vital or fatal to
our climate goals to find out I felt
drawn to The Western Isles
foreign
but first something else is back cop the
annual Global get-together of world
leaders well most of them anyway to
debate what they'll do to stop climate
change last year cop 26 was in Glasgow
this year what could be called now
that's what I call fudge 27 will be in
Egypt and it starts this weekend I like
fudge but less confectionary more facts
as our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter looks
back at the last 12 months
the world preparing for cop 27 is a very
different one to last year
a war in Ukraine has caused Energy
prices to Rocket
the weather since cop 26 has been
record-breaking
[Music]
Pakistan is drowning
an area of land that is the equivalent
of the whole of the UK is underwater
heat waves across the globe caused crops
to fail and threatened lives it's a
fast-moving confusing picture those
fires as we can see are still burning in
fact EU countries saw 16 more deaths
than usual in July as a result of
record-breaking Heat
in France a tourist haven now hell
and four years of failed rain across the
Horn of Africa has placed 22 million
people at risk of starvation
back in the UK climate has become more
politicized again
[Applause]
the government went from pledging
sweeping action on climate change if we
fail they will not forgive us to
flip-flopping over whether the Prime
Minister could even attend [ __ ] 27. the
Prime Minister has confirmed that he
will attend the cop 27 climate Summit in
Egypt after all
and a global cost of living crisis has
pushed climate change further down the
agenda
hopefully Rishi will do something about
it and there will be a way out of it so
the setting for cop27 is tougher and
less focused on climate change leaders
face a challenge if they hope to make
the African cop sema's groundbreaking as
Glasgow was
Hannah is in Egypt now at the resort of
charmel Sheikh on the Red Sea where the
conference is happening we spoke a
little earlier and she told me what we
could expect from The Summit
well at the moment that's not very clear
to be absolutely Frank there's going to
be some work about how to keep 1.5
degrees of warming Within Reach there's
going to be some work about how to give
more money to help countries adapt to
the effects of climate change that we're
already here and then there's going to
be a pretty big row about compensation
for the widespread damages that have
been inflicted as a result of climate
change and stuff that can't be adapted
to but the broad headline here Tom is
that this cop really is a test of the
planet's resolve to keep going on
tackling the climate crisis amidst War
inflation cost of living crisis
political instability and an energy
crisis you mentioned this issue about
Justice between the the Richer North and
the poorer South that strikes me that
could be particularly contentious right
now yeah I think that's actually the
thing that
out of the whole cop and it's a thing
that's keeping the organizers up at
night so I think there's a real danger
of the the low-income and developing
nations and those most vulnerable to The
Climate crisis who've done the least to
cause it
um actually you know walking out
potentially The Fragile Trust between
rich and poor Nations is already frayed
and and there is a concern that it may
well snap under the tension of these
talks and that is because if you just
think right of all the climate crises we
see develop over the last 20 12 12
months you know the floods in Pakistan
the heat waves the wildfires you name it
every corner of the globe has seen a
disaster unfold that's been driven by
the climate crisis and that and and the
nations in the global South in
particular are saying well look we
didn't do anything to cause this and
there are some issues some problems that
can't be adapted to you know someone's
going to have to pay us because we're
losing our Villages and our ability to
earn money and so on that is going to be
a particularly Hard Sell in the rich
world at the moment because the rich
World frankly isn't feeling as rich or
as powerful as it once did so that
element of uh you know generosity I know
it wouldn't be seen like that it would
be seen as justice but it's going to be
difficult to get money out of the ritual
isn't it it really is going to be tough
and you've got the EU the UK and the us
all saying actually okay we can talk
about it at this cop we still don't even
know it's going to be a formal agenda
item but what they are not willing to do
at the moment is counting as an idea of
a brand new funding facility that just
pays out every time there's a flood or
similar because they don't want to be
held liable
Hannah just briefly Before I Let You Go
that we've seen a lot of Chilly
challenge but from the UK government
about whether they're going to go or not
um it now looks like Rishi zunak is
gonna go what do we think about the UK
kind of commitment and offer here to be
honest that's been a complete mess you
know Rishi sunak you turning say he's
not going to go hearing that Boris
Johnson is actually going to turn up and
then changing his own mind and saying
okay well well maybe I'll go too that
really dented the UK's reputation as a
global Statesman a global leader and
player a convening power on the climate
crisis will it impact the outcome of the
charmel shake talks probably not it's
the UK's reputation that's taken a real
hit and we'll have to see how that will
play out in the next Fortnight and how
Rishi sunak will be able to recover from
it
so a year on from the last cop let's see
how a few numbers have shifted in 12
months actual Global temperature has
increased by
0.024 degrees at the top here is the
past week's power mix but let's compare
September last year to September this
year in a slightly different form this
radar chart it shows that the proportion
of wind in the UK's electricity mix
jumped from 18 last September to 24 this
September and this Gusty November are
records already been set the first time
wind has generated over 20 gigawatts of
electricity on a single day more than
half of our total electricity demand but
despite these achievements and world
leaders meeting in Egypt greenhouse
gases of course continue to build and
scientists are worried that this could
trigger some massive changes to our
natural world well Thomas Moore is here
to talk about this our science
correspondent Thomas is this all about
tipping points yes and they are adding
to the urgency of the talks in Egypt
because these tipping points are really
big changes to the Earth Systems you
could say life support systems because
they are so critical to moving
temperatures in the climate around the
world but the point is that once they
start they can't be stopped and they
could potentially be catastrophic sound
like a very big deal what kind of things
are we talking about yeah so we can look
at some of them so go up to the top of
the world and you've got the Greenland
ice sheet now that's two miles thick at
its uh Summit and as that ice is melting
it's coming into contact with warmer Air
at lower altitude speeding up the Melt
now if that all goes that adds seven and
a half meters to Global sea levels wow
that's taller than an average house yeah
and it gets worse because if you go to
the South you've got the West Antarctic
ice sheet now that's a series of glasses
and if one collapses then there's going
to be a domino effect if they all go
that's another three meters being added
to Global sea levels up to the top of
the world again and you've got Arctic
permafrost another of the likely ones to
to reach a Tipping Point that is a
frozen Earth which loops around the
Arctic and it contains one and a half
trillion tons of carbon historic uh
prehistoric uh animals and plants which
haven't rotted down but as microbes wake
up that's starting to happen it could be
a carbon bomb which then accelerates
climate change and then you've got uh
coral reefs in tropical Seas now 99 of
those could go and these are living life
forms and they are stressed by warm
water normally recover but the water is
now so warm that they could die now
coral reefs support fish that feed a
billion people so really important now
are these kind of immediate things or
are they a bit you know like a Hollywood
movie or are they a bit longer term many
people misunderstand what a Tipping
Point is it's not going to happen like a
Hollywood movie where it happens in a
matter of days this is something that
could happen over centuries but the
point is it's a juggernaut you can't
stop and the four that I've mentioned
there those happen at one and a half
degrees we're currently on course for
two and a half degrees of global warming
then you're going to see the loss of
Arctic sea ice the loss of mountain
glaciers and the disruption to the West
Africa Monsoon it just gets worse and
that's why Egypt is so important and the
big threat here is that they are
irreversible once they start indeed
Thomas thank you very much and indeed of
course we'd love more questions from you
you can scan the QR code here or go to
any of our social media accounts and put
your questions in the comments
and all the talk and policies around
climate change we hear a lot about
getting to Net Zero the word net here
reveals that we won't end all activities
that pump out greenhouse gases some will
continue so long as their emissions are
balanced by Cuts or absorption elsewhere
this is known as carbon offsetting some
believe it's critical to saving the
planet for others it is a dangerous
Dodge while digging further required me
to do this
[Music]
but first how do you actually offset
so many things around us emit carbon
dioxide or other greenhouse gases even
our breath for a start
and these and this and this
and this
offsetting is pain to create more ways
to reduce or remove those gases with
these and this
and that and even this stuff
so that was carbon offsetting in theory
let's go and see it in action
foreign
the Isle of Mull in the Hebrides just
off the west coast of Scotland
the island has a Timeless Beauty
Washed by the natural rhythms of weather
and the seasons
but not always
for one weekend in the Autumn the mall
rally Roars into town
the rally is the longest toughest and
most popular closed road race in Britain
around 150 cars compete day and night on
sinuous strips of tarmac that speeds
well above 100 miles an hour
this year is its 50th drivers and fans
come from across the country yet it is
frequently won by locals what do you
think the rally brings to the island
uh lots of money a nice Buzz a great
atmosphere the last bit of fun before
the winter say it's in they reckon it
brings over a million pounding it is a
thrilling sport an Indulgence a Pastime
based around the internal combustion
engine carbon dioxide is being emitted
for fun
so I thought I'd have a go
press the launch button here we go
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
oh well
I'm allowed in the co-driver's seat for
what is known appropriately as the
Shakedown stage
dress rehearsal under rally conditions
Before the Race proper because
whoa John tells me during racing they
use about a liter of fuel every mile
that's a lot of petrol being used in
this game hey
[Music]
oh hello hedge
yeah there is a difference
what we do Tom is we work out the
average fuel consumption that's expected
to be used by a rally car in liters and
we use conversion figures to translate
that into carbon equivalent and we
offset based on that for the competition
either for the competitors competing or
Spectators or the teams whatever way we
want to do it
they're all setting around half the
emissions from the competitors and The
Spectators calculated at 46 tons of
carbon dioxide that's similar to the
climate change impact of driving an
average car for 27 years I suppose the
question in the end some people would
say that yes you're giving this a
license to continue maybe for the
climate it will be better if it stopped
yes and we could say that about lots of
human activity and lots of sports you
know as I see the perception of
Motorsport because they're noisy cars
they are consuming fuel but you know if
you think about the carbon footprint of
golf or football we're all creating a
carbon footprint and it's good that
we're taking responsibility
I can safely say that was the most
exciting and somewhat scary thing I've
ever done in my life
quite extraordinary obviously the
adrenaline taps just straight on
and now we're gonna go again
[Music]
the rallies carbon sponge will be a
forest on the mainland trees absorb
carbon dioxide as they grow it's one of
the main ingredients in wood
well we're in the middle of a vast
planting area be careful not to step on
the new trees quite small at the moment
so more Forest means more carbon
captured and this year's mull rally paid
Highland carbon for a little under an
acre to be planted and cared for it
would be spectacular this will all be
native broadleaf along the Lower Side of
the bank starting from Willow and Alder
and working its way up through
Aspen and Oak and so on up and up to
conifers upon on the upper reaches how
much scrutiny and certification is are
on these projects to make sure they're
actually going to lock up the carbon
that they promise
very high level of scrutiny so all of
these projects are third party inspected
there's an inspection after the project
is completed which has already happened
there's then uh an inspection after the
first five years and then every 10 years
after that it's not just verifying the
trees are there it's there's enough
carbon stored within those trees on the
site
some drivers believe the whole sport
long-term survival rests on making this
change if you look at Formula One you
look at the World Rally Championship
World rallycross Championship all those
are adapting new technology whether it's
all electric whether it's hybrid and I
think people are realizing at the
Grassroots at the national level of the
sport that if we don't change there's
not going to be a future of the sport
for ourselves in five ten years and for
the Next Generation
Motorsport is part of the entertainment
industry
[Applause]
foreign
can offsetting and Technical fixes stop
it becoming a relic of History
well many of us might hope so but are we
just eluding ourselves I went to Oxford
to hear the view of two experts
chaitanya Kumar and Joseph bull
is climate offsetting helping our fight
against climate change or hindering I do
not believe it's actually helping I do
think there's a prospect there's a
future where carbon operating can
actually help but as of now it's
allowing companies to actually offer
their emissions without doing enough in
the first place to reduce emissions in
their own institutions because carbon
officers should be the last resort but
for a lot of companies they seem to be
the first option in terms of emission
reductions Joseph helping or hindering
as we are today well they have to be
part of the solution because we need to
get to zero emissions and start to
remove carbon from the atmosphere and
whatever we do there's always going to
be some impact right there's always
going to be some release of greenhouse
gas emissions that means we have to at
some point do offsetting if we're
genuinely serious about getting towards
zero overall emissions or drawing carbon
out the atmosphere you might hope that
we should all not be flying or that
steel shouldn't be made but it is so
given that isn't it a good idea to
offset the impact of that take for
example the steel plant as you mentioned
if I am a steel plant operator my
incentive right now should be to try and
find Alternatives instead of burning
coal to find cleaner Alternatives not to
continue burning coal and pay someone
else across the world to cut emissions
elsewhere but if you take you know zero
carbon steel at the moment that's almost
fiction I mean it's sort of happening in
some place but it's incredibly expensive
that's just not going to happen
immediately in the meantime I repeat
isn't it a good idea if that steel plant
pays for something like let's say wind
turbines to reduce emissions elsewhere
it could be a slippery slope because you
can expect a lot of these companies than
queuing up for those sort of solutions
where ultimately those projects that are
happening in India or in parts of Africa
they're not really bringing any
additional carbon emissions reductions
to the to the table an excuse for
inaction that's in a sense uh what
chitanya's saying Joseph is he right we
have to be doing something additional
that wouldn't have happened anyway to
claim a genuine reduction in greenhouse
gas emissions and that's the key thing
with these offset well let's bring it
back to our lives if you fly or if you
do particularly high carbon things do
you offset them Joseph I do and I ask my
research group to do so as well and we
spend a long time looking for the right
kind of carbon offsets a lot of the time
we think those are those that involve
some kind of active restoration of
natural habitats that's a really good
example of an offset that can be
effective because it can lead to
greenhouse gas emissions reductions or
drawdown but also potentially
biodiversity gains and that there's a
lot of parallels there and chitana do
you offset I don't fly that much but you
do things in your life that are
responsible for climate change I try and
minimize as much as possible to offset
for me as a last resort if you take for
example I came in here on my bike I only
use public transport where I go I don't
own a car and I fly as less as possible
but isn't the problem at the moment that
the suspicion that people like you put
on offsetting means that people are
basically doing neither they're
continuing to fly and they're not
offsetting I think there's a big risk
that you're individualizing the problem
here because there's obviously a
structure individuals watching this show
and then they want to know what the
guidance what they should be doing what
what we would want to see is governments
investing businesses investing and
actually greeting the transport that
we've got as you said I use Rail and
public transport which runs on fossil
fuels I'd like to see investment that
actually cleans that up as opposed to
telling me that I need to offset my
emissions as a result isn't that a sort
of making the perfect the enemy of the
good yes it would be perfect if all rail
for instance was was renewably fueled
but it isn't in the meantime wouldn't it
be a good idea to pay a little bit more
and have some trees planted or you know
renewable energy projects done as a
result of your travel I think look I've
seen this taken to an extreme where
there are companies now come up where
they're willing to offset your breath
your exhalation for a fee for about six
dollars a month you can actually offset
your carbon emissions through your
exhalation so that's the kind of
ludicrous examples we end up getting
when you individualize the problem
really think about structural solutions
to climate climate change one of the
things that makes me a little bit
suspicious sometimes of offsetting is it
seems incredibly cheap I mean you you
can fly to to Florida and they'll off
your offsetting I think it's got less
than 20 pounds it just doesn't feel
credible I think it's a major issue
because it should be more expensive and
particularly because as we both said if
you want to really solve climate change
you need to reduce emissions in the
first place and so you should be making
offsets expensive they should be a
deterrent really from from more
emissions but you would advise our
viewers to to offset but make sure
they're credible I think you should do
your best to offer to reduce emissions
first don't forget but then offsets are
valid um if you can do you know try and
establish those that are credible but
your advice would be change the system
if I'm going to offset my emissions I'm
not going to go to Africa and find out
how the treatment plant is in the right
place has it been the right tree I just
don't have the resources for that and
write another system you cannot trust
the system to actually deliver
really genuine carbon emission
reductions anywhere else in the planet
that is the problem
and just before we leave you you might
remember B4 box from our very first show
it's a greater Manchester company that
trains people from disadvantaged
communities to retrofit homes making
them more energy efficient well just
this week it won the UK low-carbon
skills award from Ashton the charity
whose mission is to accelerate
transformative climate Solutions across
the world well congratulations from all
of us here at the climate show that's
all for this week join us again next
weekend when we'll have the very latest
from cop27.